Okay. So Hi everybody and
excited to be here today.
We're here in mountain view with Michelle
gale who's joined us to talk about the
mindful parenting life in a messy world
with her latest book that just came out.
So we're very excited to have Michelle,
a little bit about Michelle before we
get started and then she'll be able to
tell us all about her messy world.
Um, and also take questions for,
for us.
And hello out there on the live stream.
Michelle is a mindfulness teacher and
executive coach specializing in working
with women leaders,
parents and organizations.
Interesting in awareness based practices.
She was previously the head of learning
and leadership development at Twitter
and spent her career working
in high growth startups.
Michele serves on the
board of the holistic life
foundation and is an advisor to
the wisdom 2.0 conference
and the mindful schools.
She has studied mindfulness education
with Mark Coleman, Jack Kornfield,
Tara Brock, and the search inside
yourself leadership institute with that.
So thank you very much Michelle.
And without further ado,
I'll hand it over to you. Yeah. All
right. Do you have enough from Michelle?
Hi everyone and hello to the
people on the live stream as well.
Um,
the last 24 hours of my life,
I've been really messy and I'm assuming
we have a room full of parents are
mostly parents. And so you did
it. You're here, you can cry,
congratulate me as well.
It was amazing that I got here and,
and it, it's a lot as a parent just to
kind of get to where you need to go.
So I'm giving you a deep bow just for
being in this room and being that this,
we're gonna be talking about mindfulness.
Why don't we just take just
a moment of pause. I love,
we have the g pause sign up here so you
don't have to change anything, you know,
to do anything. Eyes Open, eyes closed.
Just kind of following your breath
a couple of times. Breathing in
and breathing out
and breathing in.
Breathing out.
And one more time.
Breathing in
and breathing out.
Yeah. Now we're here just a
little bit more. I am too.
So I hear all great presentation. Start
with a story. That's what people tell me.
So that's what I'm going to start with.
So this is a picture.
My son Brody is the one in the Hoodie.
He's 11.
This picture wasn't taking
that long ago and um,
he had a few friends at our
house and one of the boys,
one of the other boys started talking
about a tragedy that happened in his
family many, many years ago. But
it was a pretty intense tragedy.
And the other two boys listened intently,
really listened.
They were asking some questions and there
was a real gravitas to what was going
on in the room. And I was just in
the kitchen kind of hanging back,
just observing and watching and kind
of taking it all in and all at once.
Brody, my little guy said,
I know what we need to do.
We need to have a compassion circle.
And so he took them and one of the kids
said, well, I've never done this before,
but he said, don't worry
about it. I'll, I'll tell you
what to do. You know, Cecile,
I'm feeling very proud
now that every penny,
I'm going to tell you these two
stories about my kids there.
These are like the best ones.
This isn't like life every day.
Let's make that clear, right? I
make that clear right now. Um,
but this was a good one.
So he walked them through
all sharing about, you know,
about what was just said and sending
good wishes to this past place.
And they were in the circle for a
couple of minutes and then, you know,
they went on their evening,
they kind of unlocked hands and they were
going on a night walk with flashlights
and and off they went.
But I was,
I of course as the Mama, I mean I was a
little teary eyed and a little stunned.
I mean he's done things similar
to this but not quite, you know,
he knew what to do right in that moment.
He'd had the practices in him enough
through me and I didn't teach him to go do
compassion circles.
He just had had the sense to
pause and to stop and to check in.
So one more story, and this
is my son Tyler, again,
not taken that long ago
and he's an athlete.
He is extremely active. He has two
speeds, you know, full speed, no speed.
And he's had a lot of injuries
in his very short life.
And he was subbing and a basketball
game with a friend of his,
he wasn't even supposed
to be playing in the game.
He actually was there just to watch and
they were short a player because it was
winter break. And so they asked him to
play, which he did. I wasn't even there.
I had no idea he was playing basketball.
And I get a phone call that he had
gotten pushed and shoved and fell and his
best friend kicked him,
broke his collarbone,
trying to keep the ball in, but you
know, 40 seconds left to the game.
So he was in an incredible amount of pain.
The paramedics came and got him.
We ended up in the hospital.
Of course on one side of us in the
hospital was a meth addict who's had an
infection and was not very present.
And on the other side was a man who'd
been brought in and very rare apparently I
found out later.
And the emergency room,
the trauma unit was there trying to
keep him alive and he did not stay alive
right next to us.
So Tyler experienced that and we kind
of paused together when we realized this
man had passed and send them good
wishes and put our hands on his heart.
He was an incredible amount of pain.
Apparently the collarbone is only
second to the spine to break.
So we got home very difficult to get
them in the car, to get him home,
to get them slowly down on the bed. I had
to help him go to the bathroom. I mean,
he couldn't do anything for himself.
And when I finally got him settled,
here's the, here's the
moment. He's like, mom,
I'm getting to have the experience
of what it's like to be disabled.
You are, you are. And he said,
you're getting to see what
it's like to be a disabled,
to take care of a disabled child.
I said, you're right. I am.
And then I'm gonna try not to
get weepy. He said, you know,
I'm going to have a lot more compassion
for disabled people moving forward.
And again,
you know,
I'm stunned and I got teary
eyed with him and he said,
why are you crying? Of course
he's 14 why are you crying?
And I tried to explain to him
in the best language I could,
how remarkable it was that in
the greatest pain of his life,
for sure,
he's never been in this kind of pain.
The darkest one of the
darkest moments of his life.
He knows he's not going to
play sports for a few months.
That you were able to find the learning
and the beauty in this mess that you're
in. And I told them, most adults don't,
don't get there in a lifetime,
in a lifetime. Right?
To be in that space and to see the
potential and to see the positivity.
Right?
So I love this image because we
learn the most and we have the most
opportunities to awaken and to find our
mindfulness and to find our compassion
in the most difficult parts of our lives.
Right in the cracks,
in the darkness.
This is where this is
where the opportunity is,
but we don't like that,
right? When things go wrong,
we want to push it away.
You know,
we want to push away the unpleasant and
we want to hang on to the pleasant and
that's normal.
That's what we do as human beings and
this is where these beautiful practices
that I guess I'm assuming I'm preaching
to the choir in this room and on the
live stream,
that mindfulness and compassion is
important to you and this is what these
practices offer us,
that we can start to hold the
pleasant and the unpleasant,
but you know the dark and the light,
the beauty and the Yuck in our lives
at the same time and be able to see
clearly.
I love this quote I think goes so
well with what I just shared by Rumi.
Don't turn away,
keep your gaze on the bandage to places.
That's where the light enters you.
And that's really just what
happened to my son Tyler,
and to my son Brody during
the time that there was,
they were sitting in darkness and it
was in this wounded place that the light
and turn both of them,
and we can all have those,
those experiences, and we probably
all have had them. Certainly.
When you ask people what is the greatest
learning of your life, you know,
tell me about the time that you
learned the most about yourself.
Very few people will point to something
fantastic. They weren't at Disney world,
you know,
they weren't like Dan out dancing.
Usually it's something heavy, right? It's
a sickness. It's an illness, it's a death.
It's one of those things that brings
us to those, those heavier places.
So I'm not trying to be depressing.
We'll lighten up a little bit. Um,
and I love this quote as well. By Rumi,
the cure for the pain is in the pain.
So we want to dive in.
We want to go deep.
We want to be willing to go in and
dive deep in the last 24 hours. I,
my youngest son, Brody, the
compassion, the compassion
man, how to really hard time.
He has a lot of learning differences.
School is a struggle.
We've changed schools almost every year.
He's been having a really hard time.
And he had the meltdown of meltdowns
yesterday and it took everything in me to
sit with him and find compassion.
It was really,
really hard. But I knew the cure
for the pain was in the pain.
And I knew my job was to sit with him
just like I did year after year when he
was very young and we
didn't understand why.
Always having a temper tantrum always
on the floor. We didn't understand.
We didn't know at that time what was
going on. And he's a wonderful kid,
super creative, nonlinear, um,
but a lot of barriers to learning.
And,
and when he was younger,
that was my practice to sit with him as
the temper tantrum went on and to sit
with him and to let him know,
I will hold this with you.
And that was what I tried
to offer him yesterday.
And that was when my husband
tried to offer him yesterday.
We will hold this with you. We are
willing to sit in this pain with you,
this messiness and hold this with you.
And there's light in here as well
that you can't see right now. Hey,
mindful parenting and a messy world.
That's why I named the book what I did.
So what gets in our way?
You know what gets in our way.
This tree is on the ground.
What we want is to be that,
that redwood tree standing tall.
You've probably heard that image,
you know of the Redwood, the wind comes,
the storm comes, it kind of blows over.
But then it comes back up. And I like
to add that, I didn't always know this,
but redwood trees have very deep, not
deep roots, you know, very shallow roots,
but they're connected to
community around each other.
They're connected to
family around each other.
And I think that's a beautiful
metaphor for the parenting journey,
is that this is,
this is what we do at home as a family.
No matter what that family looks like.
We have shallow roots that were all
hanging on sometimes for dear life,
but we're all hanging on
to those roots together.
And that was what we were trying
to be with my son yesterday.
And this is, this is what I
think is the big Aha for me.
I've been noodling on this
statement for a while.
Everything's fine until it isn't.
And then it is again,
and actually wrote a blog post
about it not too long ago. Um,
when I was in traveling
over the holidays and this,
this is what gets in our way because
everything's fine and then it isn't.
And then it is and we don't like
it when it's not, when it's not,
we believe something's wrong.
Yeah.
And if we're always believing
something's wrong, when it's not okay,
then we're never going to have those
opportunities to find the light in the
crack. Right. We need to be okay with our,
not okayness because let's face it,
how many parents in here parents raise
your hands? So pretty much everybody,
almost everyone.
Parenting is hard.
It's not easy.
You know,
I've been focused on these practices and
working on myself and doing inquiry and
sitting on my cushion and going
through trainings and teaching and,
and I still have a hard time. My
parenting is hard. It's not easy.
It's not meant to be easy. And we're
meant to fall and then get back up.
So here is what happens.
The movies, right?
We all have this movie in our mind
of how things are supposed to be.
We've all had this experience,
right?
We're going to someplace special with
our family and we've been thinking about
it and we have it in our mind and the
movie and what it's going to be like.
And then we get there and nothing goes
the way we planned and the movie's not
matching reality. And what happens, right?
We go downhill, we, we
kind of Sab it will,
self sabotage will
sabotage our experience.
So what mindfulness gives us,
and I'm sure you've had this experience,
is to see the movie,
right?
We see the movie playing yesterday,
all day with my son.
I saw the movie is not supposed
to be this hard, right?
That's what I'm telling myself.
I'm seeing the images of him calm and
going to school every day and not calling
and the nurse not calling me and you know,
I have this movie of what
it's supposed to be like,
but I don't buy it.
I don't buy it.
And when we have our mindfulness,
we don't buy it. Right.
And I love the image of mindfulness. You
know, this is something that happens,
like something that we assume that we
consider it as not good and in some way,
and then there's our reaction and
we don't have our mindfulness.
These two things are
right next to each other.
There's the bad thing and
then there's a reaction.
And when we have our mindfulness
and we have our compassion, no,
this space opens up and we've
all had that experience of, Oh,
this time there was a little bit of
space and I was able to make a different
choice and make a different decision.
And in family life we want
to be watching those movies.
What is the story? What is the story that
you tell yourself about your children?
What's the story that you tell yourself
about your relationship to your children
and does it match? It's an
exploration and there's no one answer,
but I encourage you to journal Journal
on those stories. What are they,
what are the stories that you
hold true about your family?
I have one about my two boys that
they're supposed to be super close,
right? Aren't brother's
supposed to be super close.
My husband and I had two
kids to live vicariously
through siblings cause
we're both only children.
So we wanted to see what it was like.
Right?
That was my first mistake that
we had this movie in our mind.
Oh we get to see siblings.
Well they are,
couldn't be any more opposite in the
world and they don't like each other that
much is the truth. You
know, they have moments.
And so I've learned to just take those
moments for what they are and, and,
and just keep planting those seeds of
love and connection between the two of
them.
But the movie is not working
out the way that I planned and,
and I work on being okay with that
not being okay because it's hard.
It's hard.
So this is,
these are all pictures of my
family and we're happy and worth
Myleene and we're connected.
Right. So what do you think,
what could you imagine all of these
pictures having common? We're on vacation.
And the other thing that all of these
pictures have in common is that there was
fighting beforehand,
not long before,
just a little while before there
was arguing and bickering. And Ah,
the day from the beach
photo that you're seeing
that full day was what I wrote this
blog post about, you know, and,
and things happen.
Like in the morning I woke up and I sat,
I did my little meditation, we
were on the water. I'm like, oh,
this is such a good moment. You know,
I love this moment. And then my,
my older son,
who's an adolescent now woke up and kind
of came into the room like, you know,
it was kind of a grunt
happened and I was like, mm,
that's not such a good moment. I would, I
had a preferred that had been different.
And then my son, my two kids were sitting
on the couch reading, not engaged,
but somewhat close to each
other, both reading very
peacefully. I'm like, oh, see,
this is so nice.
This is a nice moment.
And then it was time to leave and there
was an argument of who is going to sit
in the front.
And so that big argument happened and
I didn't like that moment and like, oh,
not okay,
this is not okay.
And then we're on the way
there and nineties hip hop
plan and we're all singing
in the car.
I'll see you were a nice normal family,
having a good time listening to music.
And then it's time to go
stop somewhere to get some food
before we go to where we're going.
And no one can agree on the food.
And everyone's got food allergies anyway.
And my husband's storm.
Yeah,
that's for three cafes to get food.
I'm like,
why does it have to be this hard? Right.
And then there we are on the beach.
Not long after, but that's the
way of that. Right? That is
the way of it. That's just
parenting. That's just family life.
And it's very easy.
And I know you have all thought,
God,
it's a really rough day.
It was a really rough day.
But if we look at the moment,
like the moment by moment by moment,
it's kind of like when you're sitting in
meditation and sometimes it's peaceful
and you know you can kind of ease into
it and then the mind goes wild and you're
just kind of trying to figure out where
you're going and hang on and then you
kind of settle again. Right. It's up and
it's down. And that's just the way of it.
So those are the pictures you didn't
see, right? You didn't, didn't
those pictures on?
It's a grammar or anywhere,
you know,
I didn't talk about how we were arguing.
Right.
I might tell my friends, but
we don't see that. Right.
We don't see that out in social media
land. We keep that to ourselves.
So you know,
all of these emotions come through.
We've got the anger,
right.
Anger comes and we're not happy.
We're not supposed to be angry.
Anger is not okay.
And the fear comes.
And I don't want to be afraid or
we don't even realize we're afraid.
We're just reacting from afraid.
And then shame comes right?
That Mack daddy emotion that
disregulates everything else.
And there's the shame that I snapped
and I raised my voice. Right?
And what if you knew that even
after all of these practices,
I still raise my voice.
I've been trying not to yell
for 10 years and I do it less,
but I still do it. And then it happens.
And immediately the shame comes.
But I have to know it's there.
I to be aware of the shame.
This is the gift. There's gotta be
a little space. So I see the shame.
And what if you knew, right? What if,
what if you knew how me and my kids work
to each other and how angry that made
me sometime. Yeah. And what
if you knew I was terrified.
I'm terrified that my kids won't
be friends when they grow up,
but they're not going to be close that
they're going to have two separate lives.
That really scares me.
Yeah,
but what we know is that
awareness is like the sun.
When it shines on things, they are
transformed the Wise Tick Nhat Hahn.
And so just even what I did
right here with you, right? The,
the Uber Vulnerability standing in front
of a room of people and sharing is all
those things are true that I shared
with you. I'm not making them up
when we shine a light on
the shame and the fear,
all right,
and the anger something happens.
It's like when we're sitting in meditation
and we're thinking, thinking, thinking,
and then we notice the thought,
right? That's our practice.
We noticed the thought like a bubble gone,
right?
We shine the light of awareness on it
and then we feel like this. We're
like, whew. You know, I, I'm aware.
I'm awake and we do that moment by moment
by moment and we do it and we teach
our children to do it and we don't teach
them to do it by telling them how to do
it.
We,
I teach my children to do that by saying
out loud what's going on for me? Right?
So I'm Sam in the kitchen and everybody's
having a hard time and I'm finding
myself really irritated.
I might say I'm really irritated.
Like I'm noticing like my jaw is tight,
my stomach feels a little sick,
my heart feels a little tight. My test
area feels a little tight. I need a break.
I'm about to say something
I don't want to say.
So I'm going to go away and I'm going
to come back. I'm going to go away,
I'm going to breathe a little bit,
I'm going to get a little space and I'm
going to come back and don't do that
every time.
Sometimes I blow it all right and I say
something I wished I hadn't said and
then I have to repair.
But the repair is just as good.
The repair is just as good as catching it,
sharing it,
making it explicit. Right? If we are,
if we as parents are practicing and
waking up and becoming more conscious and
we're saying it out loud where we're
giving them this experience to voice,
then they learn how to do it.
They learn.
Yeah.
So how, how do we do this as parents?
And many of you may already practice,
but I have something to
offer. So here we are, right?
This is the kind of what
our lives often look like.
We're falling asleep at our
desk. We're just spent, right?
We're completely spent,
we're trying to get bills paid
and we're trying to get work done.
And it's just hard. It's hard to make
it all happen. So how do we do it?
How do we do it in the course of a day?
Cause this is how I often
feel. I'm like, come on,
come on in her piece now
I don't have all day,
but we know that's
impossible, right? Sometimes.
Like why couldn't I just be one of those
people that born somewhere and just
live in a cave? And it's just what
had happened because that's just not,
it's not the life that we're living,
right?
We,
everyone here in this room,
we're all working parents and we have to
weave it in to what we're already doing.
And this is good news to experience.
Peace does not mean that
your life is always blissful.
It means that you are capable of
tapping into a blissful state of mind.
Admit a missed the normal cath,
have a hectic life and Jill Bolte
Taylor wrote the book stroke of genius.
If you've never read that, so wonderful
book and I love this quote, I'm like, Oh,
you know, we just have to be
able to tap into it and just
touch, touch, touch. Yeah,
we can have hard days.
We will have hard days.
I don't think you could be a parent and
not have a hard day whether you have one
or two or three.
So we can,
we can play.
I love these images because for me,
they all point to things that
I tried to do in my day. I,
I took on a practice not long ago, like
how many times have we heard our kids?
Like, can we play with me? Will you play
with me? And what's often the answer?
I can't on busy or making dinner.
Right. And I was hearing that, right.
My mindfulness practice help
me here. Like, oh my gosh,
I say that so many times.
And so I committed to saying Yes for one
week just to see how it would go every
time. Now this was not
when they were three, so
am I be a little different?
So you might have to say like,
I'll give myself 10 times or something.
I don't know.
This happened when they were all older,
so it wasn't happening
like 10 times a day. Um,
but I said yes.
I started saying yes and it was the best
little research study I ever did inside
of my family. We had the sweetest
week. So I kept it going.
And I can't always say yes.
Sometimes I have to say now,
but I've learned to say yes
more than I say yes. No, yes,
I'll jump on the trampoline.
I mean Jeremy on the trampolines,
Super Fun. There was a really fun
games that you play on the trampoline,
you know? Yes to the card game,
you know? Yes to the sword fight.
Yes.
And it might be that we're just
walking down a busy road. Right.
That's a great time to practice.
Walking from here to your next
meeting or back to your desk.
What if it was just a mindful walk
would if you were just really paying
attention to your feet,
hitting the ground and that was it.
Or just following your breath or just
even like feeling your hands swing from
here to wherever you're going next.
And you know when our kids are having
a hard time, can we really just pause?
Can we just stop? Can we
listen? And dinnertime,
such a good one. You
know, dinner times we,
we don't eat dinner together every night
and he's stretching the imagination.
Although I would love to, but it
feels almost impossible at my house.
But when we do,
and we do as often as we can,
we hold hands and we do this little
hand squeeze that goes around and,
and it's the sweet moment of connection
or we can be thankful for how the food
got to us.
Thank you.
The farmer that planted it and the person
that tended it and the truck driver
that came and picked it up and brought
it to the grocery store and the grocery
store person who took it out of the
track and the person who put it so
beautifully out in the grocery store or
to the farmer's market and mom or dad
who went and got it and brought
it home and cooked it and wow,
we can be grateful. We have a
gratitude jar on our, in our kitchen.
It's actually a little too big. I need
to get it a little bit of a smaller one,
but it's,
it's a big gratitude jar and it says
gratitude jar on it and I keep paper and
pen right next to it and you know,
we'll just go through practices of
every morning or at night or if we have
friends over just writing a gratitude
and putting it in. Right. That pause.
Just that moment. So we build it
into what we're already doing.
We pause, I just press the
pause button throughout the day.
And so dedicated practice that you're
seeing more in these images are important
and research tells us
that, you know, retreat,
practice and regular dedicated practice
is very supportive for our wellbeing and
for our, for our brains. And as parents,
we all know that dedicated practice
where we stop for 20 minutes, 30 minutes,
go away for a day, go away for a few
days is not always possible. You know,
when I started practicing
about 10 years ago, regularly,
I was introduced in college when
I was having a really hard time.
I went to a unity church
and sat every Sunday there.
And so that was my introduction
to guided meditation,
but I didn't start practicing regularly
until I had a four year old and a six
month old.
That was when I entered practice.
So I had to be really
creative of how I practiced.
And I remember one of my teachers,
I was complaining to one of my teachers,
I can never get to my meditation
practice and it's just never happens.
And I was all grumpy about
it. And she said, well,
tell me a little bit about your day.
So I'm telling her about my day and
I get to the end of the day and like,
and they always made me stay in their
room at night and had to stay there until
they fall asleep.
And then I,
and then I'm too tired to practice and
you know, you know what's coming next.
She's like, why don't you just sit
in their room? I was like, Huh,
why don't I just sit in their room?
So I put a cushion in their room and
we made this agreement that as they're
falling asleep at night,
I would stay in their room.
I would sit and I would do my meditation
and cuddle with them first and do our
little rituals and then
I would sit and I say,
I'm not leaving until way after you're
asleep. I'm doing my practice in here.
And I did that for years when
they were really little. Right?
So what are the things that
you're already doing that you can,
we've integrated practice that we're
talking about walking to the office or
walking down the street or
dedicated practice that you
can even do and in one of
your kids' rooms, if they're super young
and let you in, if they're teenagers,
they might not let you in.
I'm no longer allowed in at night.
Um, you know, we start where
we are, wherever we are,
wherever we are,
we can have a moment of practice.
And you all saw as soon as we came
in, we took a few breaths, right?
Everything shifts, everything shifts.
No matter how busy we are busy.
Our mind goes. Just a few
breaths. Brings us back
though.
I'm just going to run through some of my
favorite ways of weaving it into to my
day or things I like to share.
I mornings are so wonderful and you
don't have to get a bed. You know?
I've done a lot of practice with
Jon Kabat Zinn and he always says,
lay there Shavasana pose. Just open
your eyes so you're not too sleepy.
If you can close your eyes and
not fall back asleep, that's fine.
When you wake up in the morning,
just lay there and follow your breath.
Do a body scan.
You may that to get out of bed.
I will often also get up and
sit on my pillow, you know,
with my husband there and I'll just sit
and close my eyes until someone comes to
bother me and I practice not being
annoyed that I got interrupted in front my
dedication.
My Bell didn't go off yet and
I'm not done. Oh, I'm done.
It's over. I'm definitely
done the shower. Right?
I've done a lot of executive coaching.
I can't tell you how many times you've
heard this, the best ideas in the shower.
Why do we have the best ideas in the
shower? We've paused, you know, we're,
we're in sensation when we're
in the shower, the mind quiet.
So what if we did that intentionally when
we got in the shower and we just felt
the hot water on our body and we just
allowed ourselves to be there in the
shower.
One of my favorites,
I love my cup of tea in the morning.
I'm a big fan of Earl grey tea and usually
gets pushed off and gets pushed off.
I boil the water and my husband's like,
the water's boiling again. I'm like,
I know,
but I still would've made my tea.
I'm dying to make my team and
I keep getting interrupted.
And then there's that moment to me.
It's one of the magical moments of my day
that I stopped and I just put my hands
on the cup and I smell it and just give
myself 30 seconds or a minute to just
enjoy the heat of the water.
I love this image. I, when I
saw this image, I thought, oh,
what a great practice. So I tried
it and it sounds a little hokey,
but it works every time.
For one day I tried it and then
I continued it every day I,
every time I caught a glimpse of
myself in the mirror or in my computer,
I would say something kind to myself.
I would send myself some kindness like
you're depending on the day, right?
It might've been you're doing the
best you can, you know, I love you.
Whatever it might be,
I just send myself some kindness
and mindful listening. You know, kind
of mentioned that a little bit earlier,
but if you practice mindful listening,
it's just that stopping and noticing
any thoughts that are in your mind when
someone's talking.
Are you trying to respond or you really,
really gifting your presence
and with our children,
particularly any older besides
me, teenagers in here, a few,
few teenagers mindful listening for all
of you that are on your way to teenage
hood, it's so critical. And the
car right, they get out of school,
they get in the car. When a most of
us do from the time they're little.
How was your day? What happened,
you know, how was your test?
We start pummeling them with all these
questions and they what often they shut
down. Even little ones. Well sometimes,
I mean the little ones still
want to tell you everything,
but certainly as they get older,
that's it.
So I've learned,
you know,
I picked them up and I just nothing
and just say, I'm happy to see you.
I'm so happy to see you.
That's it.
And almost always the conversation
will come and it's on his terms,
not my terms. And so it arises
out of the car, use the car.
And by the way,
when they come to be teenagers,
they sit in the back with their friends
and for some reason you're not there.
You get all kinds of
good information.
How do you not know that I'm
sitting right here? Yeah.
So great. And just don't say anything.
I love this image to sitting in the car.
Also dropoffs pickups.
Anybody you have to drop the kids off
or pick them up at an activity. Anybody.
Yeah,
lots of activities in the car.
Beautiful place for dedicated practice.
And I dropped my kids off to Jujitsu or
baseball or wherever they were going and
I'd sit in the car for five 10 15 minutes
or at pickup to sit in the car for
five, 10 15 minutes. Use
your insight timer. Simple
habit. By then, simple habit.
I did a seven day series for parents.
It is five minutes a day,
so if that supportive,
I'm not sure if it's free or not,
but it is on simple habit.
Headspace.
Put your ear buds in, sit in
silence, had a guided meditation.
Just sit in the car.
Oh,
and the smile, the smile. We
can really take in the smiles,
right? The Joy. We can bring
the joy and more fully.
So I really encourage you all to make a
list. It doesn't have to be right now,
but remember to make a lift of what
you do from the time you wake up in the
morning till the time
you go to bed at night.
I'll do this with parents and workshops.
I'm doing a workshop here next week.
Maybe we'll do that.
Make that list and look and
see where can you weave.
In a moment of mindfulness. I mean,
be really specific, you know, wake up,
walk to the bathroom, you to
take my shower, make my tea,
make lunch for my kids.
Right?
Where can you weave in
a moment of mindfulness?
Okay.
Because it really is, it's, you
know, we've heard this, this phrase,
it's like exercise. It's like
building a muscle, right?
We have to build that muscle and so we
have to practice over and over and over
again.
One of my teachers gave me a centering
practice that I did 50 60 70 80 times a
day, depending on what my day was
like. I would do it more. I'm like,
kids were very young. I couldn't
get away to a retreat. In fact,
I thought I was the biggest
fraud meditation person
because I'd never been on a
retreat and I was bemoaning this to one
of my teachers and they really stopped
me in my tracks and said, no,
Michelle, this is the gift, right?
This is what you're going to get to share
and this is what we all need to learn.
His parents.
That just those moments again and again
and again cultivates an awakened life
and that's what we all want. We want
to live awake, we want to be mindful
so
we can, we can feel the joy is, it's
not just so, it's not just about,
I like to say it's not just about the
sadness and it's not just about like
dealing with the frustration
and the pain and the anxiety,
which sounds so wonderful for,
that's what brought me to practice.
I have a lot of natural anxiety.
I have it right now and it's not
because I'm nervous. I haven't,
most of the time my chest is tight,
my belly is a little tight.
I always kind of feel like I
can't breathe in all the way.
I was just born that way and that was
one of the things that brought me to
practice,
so it's wonderful for those things and
we can experience the joys even more.
Right?
We can really smell the scent of our
baby's hair when they first get out of the
bath in the morning.
And we can watch them play and see them
learning new things as they get older.
And just being, aw, I,
we want more moments of awe
and practice brings us to our,
and it brings us to a fierce heart.
And here is what I think is one of
the most magical parts of practice for
anyone,
but particularly for parents because our
heart is going to get broken over and
over and over again.
And we're going to find our lives and our
heart on the floor in a million pieces.
And you know, from those movies,
movies that weren't working out,
and we're going to pick it up,
I'm going to put it back together.
And each time we put it back together,
it gets stronger.
And the question we all have for
ourselves is, can my heart remain open?
When, when things are
hard, you know, can I,
can I have that fierce open heart?
Okay.
And it's okay that it's cracked and
it's okay that it's not perfect,
right? We're not, we're not
trying to perfect ourselves.
We're trying to perfect our love.
And I have a story I'll read you.
I think we have enough time.
I love this story. I, the
first time I heard it was um,
from Tara Brock and it is from,
it's written by Richard Selzer.
It's from stories for the heart compiled
by Alice Gray and it's called the kiss.
I stand by the bed where a young woman
lies her face postoperative her mouth
twisted in Palsy.
Clownish a tiny twig of the facial nerve.
The one to the muscles of
her mouth has been severed.
She will be best from now
on. Nevertheless, to remove
the tumor from her cheek,
I had to cut the little nerve.
Her young husband is in the room.
He stands on the opposite side of the bed
and together they seem to dwell in the
evening.
Lamplight isolated from me private.
Who are they?
I asked myself,
he and this rye mouth I have made who
gaze at each other and touch each other.
So generalists generously.
Well my mouth always be like this.
She asks. Yes, I say it will be.
It is because the nerve was cut.
She nods and is silent,
but the young man smiles.
I like it.
He says it's kind of cute all at once.
I know who he is,
I understand and I lower my gaze.
One is not bold in an encounter with God.
Unmindful he bends to kiss her
crooked mouth and I am so close.
I can see how we twists his
own lips to accommodate her,
to show her that their kiss still works.
Okay,
so can we show ourselves and can we show
our children and our families over and
over again?
Each time you take a downturn,
can we show them that it all still works?
So when the anger appears, can
we do that? You turn right.
Can we notice the anger?
Have that pause?
Can we do the u turn and come in
and explore? Can we get curious?
What is this anger? Where is it coming
from? What's it about right? As soon,
you know, curiosity kills
anger in a second. The second
we get curious about it.
There's a,
there's some space and then we have the
opportunity to do something a little
more creative than we
might've done otherwise.
And when the fear comes, right, we
notice it, it arises. Can we stop,
do the u turn and come in and notice,
ah,
this fear and John is Zinn often says,
and this too,
and miss two,
I can include all of this
and we get curious
and then the shame,
can we do the u turn and see
what is this about this shame?
Can I explore it?
Can I understand it better?
Okay.
And then we give ourselves
in self compassion.
I'm a student of Kristen nefs work.
If you haven't studied her,
she was the one of the original,
really the original
researcher on self compassion.
And she shares that what we,
what we need to do when we're
in these states of, you know,
really being hard on ourselves is to be
mindful, to bring up our mindfulness,
to realize that common humanity,
right? We all go through this.
Everyone in this room,
if you look around,
we were all going through this together,
that it can be hard and
it can be beautiful and it
can be miserable and can be
fun, right? We're common humanity.
This is your tribe, right?
In this room.
We're all connected by being parents
and them being kind to ourselves and
from the research she says, you know,
always put your hand on your heart.
So when I was doing that little
mirror exercise, I tried.
If I wasn't into strange of a place
to say something nice with myself,
put on my heart or just anywhere you
know, on my body, just to touch myself,
let me know.
Let myself know,
hm. You know, a little bit of kindness.
This is reality for most
people in this room.
For most people who are listening on
the live stream, this is the reality.
This is how it's going to be.
It's going to be up, down.
Everything's fine until it
isn't than it is again, right?
Mindful parenting and a messy world.
That's what we're living and we can,
we can respond more skillfully, right?
That's what you hear over and over again.
When you learn about mindfulness, it's
all in the choice of moving from that.
We live this autopilot life to get to
choose what's my response going to be in
this moment,
right?
So we can choose
hello to go down those dark places and
sometimes we are going down the dark
places. Last night I was kind of
pooped, you know, we'd been to,
I'd been kind of with
my son for hours and I,
the compassion just wasn't coming and my
husband brought the light for a little
while. I didn't have any more
light to give. And that's okay.
That's okay. All right. And we're blessed
if we have a partner, right, that we can,
that we can share that with.
Not everyone does,
but we can go to that side where we
can shine the light of awareness on the
fear, on the shame, on
whatever's going on for us.
And I don't always get it right,
but these guys in these
faces keep me very motivated.
And I'm sure you have your
own faces in your phone.
I wish I could see all of them. But this
is why we will, this is why we practice.
We practice for ourselves.
We practice for the world and we
practice for our families. And they are,
you know, they will bring us to our knees
in spiritual practice, our children,
right.
They will trigger every un UN
dealt with issue from childhood.
We have.
And that's also their gift to us
because they point us to our freedom.
They point us to where
the work needs to happen.
And I am very grateful to be on this
path with all of you in this room and
everyone listening.
Thank you.
Yeah.
So we'll take questions.
Anyone have a question in the room?
Hi Madison from Brazil.
I'm very glad that I eat.
I'm here just to gather
the yard talk here, uh,
at the same moment. So my,
my point is about emotions.
How you call or you teach somehow
about emotions for your children.
How do you teach them about
emotions? Yeah. Emotional
intelligence, but not this,
this kind of approach and
more like natural approach.
Yeah. Yeah. Um, yeah, that's um,
well one idea that I share with my
kids is naming the emotion right in,
there's some wonderful research on this.
Matthew Lieberman I think in 2014
talked about does naming the emotion,
how that clears the prefrontal Cortex,
calms the Amygdala.
So we teach them just to
name it, you know, like, and,
and I think that's in a lot
of the parenting literature
now. Oh, you're angry,
right? Oh, you feel sad. And it might
seem a little Hokey, you know, to do that.
We do it more often when they're young.
Um,
but we can also inquire with
them when they're older.
Like what is the emotion and if you can,
depending on your child,
my kids are kind of used to it now.
Like where is it in your body located?
Is there a color? What does
it feel like? Like, so they,
what we want is for them to get to know
their emotions and the body is where
they live.
We experienced them in the body long
before they come into cognition.
And another little trick with emotions
that I also like to share his time them.
So when they were really little and
they'd say, I'm so angry and like, wow,
you're really angry. Let's see how long
it lasts, how long can you be angry?
Right. And put on the timer, let's
see how long it can be angry.
And now it's a game. Right? So now
it'll pass quickly. But you know,
cause now they want to see how
long it can pass. But you know,
within 60 seconds or a minute, you
know it's gone. And so they see, oh,
so what, what we're teaching
them is it comes and it goes,
it begins and it ends. Have you ever
been angry all day? I'll ask them.
Well No, not really. It's usually not
that way. It's usually not that way.
So that helpful. Many
else, hold on one second.
One off the mic.
Thank you. Thank you for being here
and sharing your story. So yeah,
quick question.
Like you mentioned there is,
let's say structured practice that
you sit and meditate and there's being
mindful drone turn your day.
And then you mentioned a lot of different
ways have to teach to the letter one.
Have you ever tried to do
like a structured practice,
meaning less sit down together and have
a meditation session with your kid?
Yes.
Well I,
the way I came to teaching meditation
was actually went through the mindful
schools program.
I liked,
cause I wanted to teach it to my kids
at home and I ended up teaching in their
school. So I taught in their school
as a volunteer for three years.
So they got it from me there and I found,
at least for me anyway at home to
actually try to explicitly teach it.
Most kids won't, most kids
won't. But I let them see me.
Right. So if they come in my
room and I'm sitting right,
I love Jon Kabat Zinn tells this
story of, you know, his son will have,
is zen as a mindfulness teacher in his
own right, his spirit rock and all around.
And, um, and he would say he'd be
sitting, John got up very early to sit,
four in the morning all the time, you
know, did his whole yoga and meditation.
And he says he never ever asked
his kids to sit in meditation,
but they'd come in and they'd see him
sitting and he'd have a blanket around and
he said he'd opened the blanket,
you know,
and they'd come in and he'd
close the blanket and that
image to me, so beautiful.
And then they just sit there with him in
meditation. So depending on your child,
some kids will eat it up.
Books are a really great way.
There's so many moody cow Meditates,
I think it's called.
And I mean there's a whole bunch
of beautiful children's books.
And so reading I did, we did a lot
of reading, but explicit teaching,
I think it's in the weaving and
I think it's in the pausing.
Before my kids used to go to
school, um, when they were younger,
they started walking alone and I was
all freaked out and like so weird.
Like they're leaving without me and
I don't like it. And, and so for me,
this is a me practice. I'm like, would you
guys be willing to hold hands, you know,
do our little circle like we do at dinner
and do a little hand squeeze and take
one breath. Like okay, you know, they
were willing to do it and then they,
if I forgot,
they would ask for it.
So that probably went on for
three or four months, you know,
every morning before they left for school.
One breath.
So my encouragement is to weave it in.
And if you have a child that is really
excited to learn, then go for it. Yeah,
I have question. Yeah. So tantrums.
What's the mindful response?
What would be a best practice if you've
just got someone who's tantruming a lot,
big time. Yeah. Well I think, you
know, there's a few layers to that.
There's always like, what's
under the Tantrum, right?
So that's always where from a
mindfulness perspective, right?
Where it's never the
behavior, right? It's always,
there's some emotional reaction and what
is the emotion and what is, you know,
it nonviolent communication,
very nonviolent communication.
What's the need that's not
being met? You know, and I love,
I think Dan Siegel does
halt, hungry, angry,
lonely, tired. You know, you can ask
yourself, hungry, angry, lonely, tired.
So it doesn't know what's under it,
what's causing it.
And if you can get them to
share, wonderful. Some in
the middle of a Tantrum,
not always, but then it's being
able to, like I was saying earlier,
to hold it so they know
I can hold this with you.
You're not alone in this.
We can be in this together.
And just that alone trying to stop
it is, you know, unless you know,
sometimes you're in the middle of a store
and you're like, how about a twizzler?
And that works. And that's just,
sometimes it's just survival.
But if you've got space
in time, hold it. Great.
Thank you so much. I think we're
at time. Thank you so much.